he was like oh oh man
oh I probably should have told this a
long time ago he's like he's like yeah
if you're gonna be having sex you got to
use condoms and I was like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
welcome to another amazing episode of
careful boys
the lovely Anthony Lee and Colleen
Leinart wow
all right I wanted to know uh from you
guys because I don't think we've ever
talked about this but uh-oh what was the
first thing your parents taught you
about gay people
oh [ __ ] that's a good question so my uh
my uncle
um was gay and I didn't understand like
what that really was but my uncle used
to like always come visit and he would
always bring he would always like load
his whole [ __ ] station wagon up with
like stuff from the thrift store
when he would come with his friend and
then like it was like him and his friend
hanging out in our place for a couple
days but like I didn't know that that
meant like him and his friend were like
you know Best Buds and like all kinds of
other stuff I just thought that their
butt you know their friends
but then
um
I just think that they didn't know how
to bring it up to me
um and then when my uncle eventually
like like this is all during all the aid
stuff like the 80s and 90s like my uncle
actually everyone got told that my uncle
has AIDS
and then
um my parents were just like it was from
a dirty needle like that's that's what
they said that's what they said and so I
was so I was like young enough where I
didn't really understand any any of that
um but then later on like this is
probably like 10 years later or yeah
probably 10 years later I remember my my
mom was hearing like a bunch of [ __ ]
from you know you're a kid you talk a
lot of [ __ ]
and we were we had just you know we were
at that age where anybody talking about
you being gay you have to like be like
and I think my mom saw me doing that and
she's like you know your Uncle Bob was
gay and then I was like what I was like
Uncle Bob was gay and she she would like
tell me and like she was like yeah he
was he was he was gay and I kind of
ended up putting him together later on
that like you know he had he died of
AIDS like during all that stuff which
was a huge thing yeah yeah and then um
my mom just just telling me that they're
just like anybody else like treat them
just like the same amount of respect you
have for your neighbors like that we
always raise you to have respect for
your neighbors it's the same idea and
not I was like holy [ __ ]
so yeah wow I did not have that from my
parents uh my mom I think anytime I
would just joke about it because I knew
I think once I started understanding
that she was so like
uh Asian by the book with certain things
and that also means like it's very
complex to talk about things you don't
confront a lot of things you don't
[ __ ] you know what I mean if I would
even joke around and be like like Mom at
this I'm this black girl and she'd be
like what because you know what I mean
that's just like how it always was or
anytime like if I want to go further
with it you know eventually learn I'd be
like well I'm gay and she's like in
Vietnamese like don't say nonsense like
that you're crazy so it would just
always be this like short yeah
dismissive joke about it you know what I
mean so I just never had any
conversation of actual depth or anything
with my parents about stuff like that I
would just cut it off right away I just
learned from friends and school and TV
and everything else yeah which which I
also just like I also respected my
parents
their own upbringing and maybe the way
trying to think about like maybe the way
they were raised you know what I mean or
the way they were taught things or the
things that they were exposed to versus
being like you're ignorant you know what
I mean you guys don't get you have to
understand you know I'll just kind of
like all right so you don't understand
but that's okay
or maybe they do and we just can't we
have a language barrier we'll never
really be able to communicate in a way
that like this is going to be
intellectual or I'm going to grow from
it you know what I mean so is it is it
something you guys feel like you'll ever
get on the same page about or even the
same understanding about or it's just
one of those things like you're just
gonna have your thoughts I have my
thoughts I don't care if we ever even
know if we see eye to eye or anything I
think on topics like like homosexuality
it's not so directly involved in my life
uh so I don't necessarily need to like
figure out how to build that bridge of
conversation but I'm sure you know even
to [ __ ] have a conversation about
like having children or or even the idea
of like religion you know I feel like
those are things that are more I'm still
more Curious to be able to like figure
out how to have those conversations with
my parents you know what I'm saying the
one where I did have to try to build a
bridge was I haven't talked to my mom
and my dad in so long when kovid came
around ain't no one like the whole
vaccine stuff came that's like people
felt very strong only a certain way or
the other and it was kind of weird I was
like oh [ __ ] am I about to like have a
political conversation with my parents
because I don't know where they sat on
things and this I'd be like oh hey Mom
like are you going to get that vaccine
and I'm like Hey Dad are you gonna get
the vaccine and it was just crazy
they're complete opposite I'm like no
vaccine don't trust nothing Western
missing my dad's oh I got vaccine right
away you gotta be safe we gotta protect
each other and I was like oh [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] normal
I didn't think it was gonna be so polar
opposite
that's why they're not together exactly
exactly for my for me um mine was I
think in early college so there's like
this Asian Trope which is pretty true
where like no boyfriend and girlfriend
in high school
then once you get in college like when
you're about to graduate it's like how
come you don't have any kids it's like
this is this weird thing and then so my
dad's like you need to have you need to
[ __ ] start having some kids man and
I'm like I don't even have a girlfriend
so I don't know how it's gonna happen
and uh my dad's like you don't need one
you just need to have a girl you have a
baby because I'm getting to that age
where I need a grandson and then I
remember one time what if I was gay
and I can't even impregnate a girl or
whatever and I would just sell my dad's
like brain [ __ ]
no you you Chinese you're not gay I'm
pretty sure there's Chinese gay people
out there yeah yeah probably more than
anyone in there
just billions and billions
mathematically that's true the odds are
his brain was just [ __ ] I was just
like oh [ __ ] I can't believe I [ __ ]
made his brain malfunction I need to
[ __ ] control I'll delete his ass so
he never talked to you about it when you
were a kid never wow yeah never ever my
parents didn't really talk about like I
was really right when you asked that I
was like man I don't think yeah I can't
think of a scenario that yeah I had a
conversation about it or it was brought
up or like they explained blamed it you
know like just the other night my wife
was like when did your parents have like
the sex talk with you and I was like
dude I vaguely remember it I don't
really remember it at all and it was
just like very basic and that was it so
like as far as like the gay conversation
I think I learned everything through
like movies and TV and through like
friends like that was how I learned
everything but then the one time my dad
ever like brought this up to me kind of
like what he said to you it was like I
think I was a junior in high school and
where it was me my mom my dad and we
were on a road trip to San Diego and my
mom was in the convenience store or
something my and it was like a Windstar
Ford van so it was like three rows and I
was like all the way in the back because
I was a cool kid
wow that's so cool man my dad's in the
front he's like 350. and he just looks
in the rearview mirror and he goes hey
Nick uh
do you like
talk to girls
at your school
and I'm like
what do you yeah yeah I talked to girls
like what are you talking about he's
like no I just want to make sure they're
like you know he's like you have like
girlfriends and stuff like do you
do you talk to girls actively and I was
like
this my dad never like asked questions
like this you know ask questions about
like my day-to-day life or anything like
that like every now and then it'll be
like General stuff but like for him to
go in that in depth I'm just like
already like oh Dad come on man that's
like the scene in Dahmer yeah
do you think you're that took your dad a
while to build up he's like I think my
son's gay I'm just gonna probably
approach this thing he probably was like
I don't know I don't know what my dad
thought of us like I have no idea so and
it was like always depending on his mood
so the fact that he even asked me that I
was like this is so [ __ ] weird but
that's probably as close as we've ever
talked about and then as far as like my
sister was dating this girl for a while
and when she told my mom about it for
the first time like that was kind of a
weird thing
because I wasn't expecting my mom to
react the way that she did like she was
kind of like disbelief like she just
kind of didn't really like it did the
ball it didn't and it because that's the
thing it's like it didn't really make
that much sense to her she just like
couldn't she's like what like it was it
was kind of like that what kind of uh
what kind of type of lesbian was your
sister like the lipstick type or like
the bush style you know what I'm saying
like oh is that lit up or not really
like she really just looked like a
regular kind of girl a lot of flannels
she's hybrid bro Von Dutch she could do
both oh she she [ __ ] rocks she could
dress up real nice she's just seeing if
there was signs no it would also not be
as much as no I'm not sure your sister
exists according to Anthony's London
yeah my sister's not real
um did you hear about that no but like
when she was having this conversation
with my mom like me sitting there and I
was like pretty I was like I was like
maybe
like early 20s like super early 20s so I
and I didn't I wasn't really really good
at like conversating having these like
hard difficult conversations but I just
was sitting there in the room there's a
lot of crying there's a lot of like
uh like maybe a little bit of shouting
here and there like just trying to get
on the same page a little bit between
your sister and your mom yeah there's a
lot of attention and then what was the
shouting coming from from disappointment
or from like no way like this belief or
well my sister was already kind of like
the way the conversation was going my
sister was really a little upset you
know so she kind of was just like a
little obviously it's very emotional she
didn't really know how to like navigate
this conversation at the same time too
it's like sometimes you're saving face
with how you have conversations with
your parents because you don't want to
like
upset them or make them feel some type
of way so sometimes there was points
where I felt like ah maybe she's like
saving
leaving some things out to save my mom's
feelings a little bit you know because
my mom didn't really take it the best
way but that was really interesting but
over time that changed because the way
she saw my sister and her girlfriend in
Iraq like she was just then she became
part of the family and it wasn't really
a thing at all but initially it was just
like what like what huh like she kind of
was shocked her dad take it that
[ __ ] demon oh bro like that's
the thing like he
this is the thing about my family dude
like this dude he I don't think he
really knew about it until like two
three years in years
so she would bring the same girl around
they were like best homie they were like
best homies they'd always kick it so we
would always be like oh it's just both
like she was just part she would always
come over and be at the crib all the
time you know having sleepovers all the
time and your mom didn't talk to your
dad about it
or do you think see that's the thing
it's like it's like she told him and
he's like that's nice honey
you talk to guys
you actively you're acting talking to
dudes like I think he just was so he
also doesn't not have these
conversations either like he doesn't
know how to preface dad asks his
daughter that question yeah like and it
just never came up so like I think
eventually they found out yeah once they
found out
it she just never brought it up he just
always like how's that like how
so-and-so oh good cool and that was it
wow it's like a silent understanding
silent understanding even to this day
like he was asking he asked me a couple
of like maybe like a year ago they had
broken up but he goes hey are they still
together and I'm like dude that's like
[ __ ] old news bro for years two years
ago that uh for a guy that doesn't hear
a lot of things he's kind of ironic it
works in sound design
seriously dude he sounded effects not
dialogue difference
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah that's good that's good that's a
good time now that's good we talked to
girls
you actually shut up please hold I gotta
get this
you know you know the only time my dad
talked to me about girls uh it was
really late I was already traveling and
teaching like choreography straight up
uh but I mean I think he just knew that
I'd have girlfriends from time that's
crazy you already like 40 deep this is
talking about like uh sex this is him
trying to talk to me about sexual digits
shut the [ __ ] up
this is him trying to talk to me about a
sec right he like picks me off from the
airport and I'm coming back from this
trip and stuff and then uh you know
we're just talking on in the traffic and
he's bringing up stuff he's like so you
know and I've already been to like hella
places and finally it's like so you know
you go out there
you you teach like yeah you know this
and he's like yeah and you
hang out I was like whoa but yeah I mean
you you got you know definitely have fun
sometimes you throw events I'm trying to
give them details like you okay so
and then you uh
you uh and I already started to know
where this is
I was like give you a heart to Christ
why is he tiptoeing so much because they
don't know how to [ __ ] put the words
together you know it's weird yeah a lot
of it is like just even vocabulary like
what's the appropriate vocabulary to
like [ __ ] talk to your children about
something that's appropriate you know
and and there's no way in hell he can be
scientific about and be like do you guys
have sex there's no way is there
Vietnamese equivalent of like a slang
you could say I they've never taught me
a third grade language oh okay you know
what I mean
um but
finally he's just like okay so you hang
out with the you know other other people
students wow not even girls wow
and I was like
you hang out with you yeah I'm me I'm
like so then at this point at this point
it was like so [ __ ] like moving the
needle like every [ __ ] hundred years
so I'm like
hang out with people I meet a lot of
people sometimes they're girls oh and
I'll show you that I said that because I
was like where's this going you're
smiling right after he goes
high five
yeah he's like no
um and then from there the second I
broke the ice I thought this was
actually gonna turn into I was like damn
I'm actually gonna have a talk with my
dad at like 20 something yeah and then
he ends it with going you have to be
smart okay
wow that's it it doesn't tell you it's
always a lesson that's it just gotta be
smart you know what you know what my
talk with my dad was so his was like
once we started getting booking for
shows and stuff going everywhere he was
like Hey so you know when you get famous
lots of people are gonna like you
and he goes
but you and Gio are strong oh see that's
good that's already so death and it's
what he calls he goes so
put the money in the envelope gift to
them
heart stay with Geo
other people only money only kids
everywhere else
but you're real kids here I'm like he
said only kids every allegations that my
mom had that like my dad cheated on her
I was like yeah I'm pretty sure you did
yeah yeah
teaching you like Good Fellas yeah he
was just like what I'm getting from this
is that you cheated so I think pretty
much it's like these are all side
[ __ ] don't let side like side [ __ ]
are cool don't let it affect your real
[ __ ] like your priorities
side [ __ ] are for money and this is
your heart
dude I was oh [ __ ] so my talk with my
dad was it came like because of urgency
so so
um I used to I used to I used to work at
my dad's business right and one day I'm
going to the bathroom and I'm and I'm
I'm peeing blood oh [ __ ] and I'm like
holy [ __ ] why the [ __ ] blood and then
does it look bright red what is peanut
butter it looks like blood whoa It's
like oh [ __ ] so I'm like [ __ ]
screaming yeah dude I was like so
confused why the [ __ ] women peeing
blood right yeah so then um then and I
had this pain I had this pain like like
in my in my side for a while too and it
would like jolt out of nowhere and I was
like what the [ __ ] is that pain so I'm
not I'm paying blood until then I'm like
Hey Dad I'm like I just I was just in
the bathroom and I peed blood I don't
know what the [ __ ] going on he was
like he was like holy [ __ ] he had no
clue about it at all he was like holy
[ __ ] he was like he was like oh oh man
oh I probably should have told her this
a long time ago he's like
he's like yeah if you're gonna be having
sex you gotta use condoms and I was like
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
he was wait wait wait where are you guys
going oh man
because I hadn't really had sex so I was
like I was like this isn't what's going
on yeah like but but he but he was
immediately like beating himself oh no I
should have told you this [ __ ] a long
time I'm a ruined Man
Steve got it yeah he's like what the
[ __ ] did I do no so then so I got the
class so then the pain got worse and
worse and it was my first kidney stone
experience but we didn't know but my dad
is immediately like my son has an STD I
didn't [ __ ] tell him I can't believe
this [ __ ] he was like beating himself up
instantly but like oh my God that's
[ __ ] funny all right oh geez yeah oh
God
just a kidney stone right well I was not
a very sexually active you
foreign
[Music]